When you were a child, you were very musical.
Yes.
And you wanted to be in musicals, I mean, what was a dream that you had?
I knew I was very musical.
Yes.
But it wasn't necessarily that I dreamed of having a music career until later in life.
I knew that music was in my life and I knew that music was my greatest joy.
Yeah.
But I wasn't thinking about a job.
I wasn't thinking about that kind of thing.
So it wasn't until I was maybe 14 that I started to realize, "Oh my gosh!"
"Wouldn't it be amazing if I could actually make a living..."
"...doing what I love, making music."
And so it kind of, it found itself in different ways.
I took acting, I loved theater, I loved the arts.
I kept writing music, I did musical theater and opera.
I just kinda did a lot of things and eventually it turned into kind of this last ten-year journey...
...of what these CDs are and I can't believe that it actually came true.
I see.
Yeah, it sounds like... I mean, reading your biography, it sounds as if like...
...it just happened rather than you actually planned in how to.
It did just happen.
There's always preparation.
Luck is preparation meets opportunity.
Yeah, definitely.
And so, I think that in my preparation was that because I love music so much,...
...I was constantly playing it.
So, I was learning and I was taking voice lessons.
I'm not self-taught vocally.
Right.
So, I was doing it for the sheer love of it and then the opportunity came.
And the door was open and I had to walk through the door.
But then, every day after that happened, it's been a wonderful learning experience.